hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel this is a
property investment channel where i help
as many of my subscribers as possible
become financially free meaning that i
can leave their jobs through property
investment and often it happens within a
matter of 12 months it can take longer
but the more videos you watch and the
more you take action the quicker it's
likely to happen so if you enjoy my
channel please do me a massive favor and
smash the like button also if you're not
subscribed that is the first step to
becoming financially free so subscribe
to the channel right now turn the
notification bell on and in this video
i'm going to be answering questions from
my subscribers so if you'd like me to
answer one of your questions whether it
be around property or business finance i
will do my very best to answer your
question so comment below in the comment
box and i'll answer your questions next
week let's see what questions we had
last week and while i'm answering
questions please do feel free as i'm
answering questions to if you get an
offshoot of a question just throughout
the video comment your question below so
we had sw say
when you're offering a lease option
agreement
do you make sure that they have a buy to
let mortgage or if they just have a
standard mortgage can you rent it out
like that hope you can reply mate of
course i can reply that's what i do so
if you're doing a lease option agreement
which is when you buy a house now and
you pay for it later i think the
question is in the meantime when you've
controlling the property
can you rent it out um if it's got a
mortgage and the answer is yes you can
if number one the mortgage is a buy to
let mortgage number two if there's no
mortgage number three if you have
consent to rent it out the only reason
you wouldn't be able to rent it out
would be if it was on a residential
mortgage and the lender
prohibited the property from being
rented out while that mortgage was still
in place if that happens all you need to
do is get the owner to ask for a letter
of consent which normally they'll do
because normally the lender especially
if there's been a change of
circumstances with the owner normally
the lender just wants their uh interest
paid so with a letter of consent you
don't have to refinance you can rent the
property out sometimes they say no in
which case you might just have to find
another property hope that helps
okay lucie should i do brr method in a
place as london where i'm starting out
or should i do it in a cheaper place
with cheaper houses starting out okay so
if you're doing a buy refurbished
refinance deal it does work in london or
the outskirts of london very well it
also works in cheaper areas some pros
and cons i'll say is the pros of doing
it near london is number one you live
there so you're gonna be able to manage
the property easier and also you know
the area well and you need to know the
area well
the cons of doing it in or around london
is houses are really expensive so you're
gonna probably need more money initially
to put down up front even though you'll
hopefully get it back up on the
refinance but also when you do refinance
it might be that the rent doesn't really
cover the mortgage because houses are so
expensive around london so it might be
better starting off further up north you
get the experience up north you'll be
able to get more cash flow and then once
you've understand the strategy and
you've done it potentially consider
moving
closer to home but there really are pros
and cons to each so i would just say
make sure you're comfortable you know
the area well and ultimately the numbers
stack up
if you enjoyed the video by the way
don't forget to hit like
okay top man says hi samuel i don't feel
good raising rents on current tenants
i feel you bro i do feel you
will i lose a lot of money not doing
this or will the increased turnover from
raising rents balance it out god bless
you and your family so top man
it's really interesting my philosophy on
raising rents is this
generally speaking i like to reward my
tenants for staying a long period of
time by not increasing the rents as much
as i could so let me give you an example
i've got properties in birmingham and
i've got tenants in there paying 700
pounds they've been paying 700 pounds
for years
i know
that i could very easily rent it for 900
pounds a month but the thing is
they've been in their years i like them
they're really low maintenance they plan
on staying there a very long time so i
made the decision instead of putting the
rent up to 900 to put the rent up just
to 775
that way they're still getting a really
good deal they're not gonna they're not
gonna move out but then i'm putting the
rents up but it's a bit of a compromise
so i would probably advise
don't be a mug don't just leave the
rents and you know if if the rent's
worth a grand but they're paying 500 i
wouldn't just blow oh well but at the
same time i'm not going to push it up to
the actual market value necessarily i
might do it a little bit lower just as a
way of saying thank you for them being
long-standing tenants hope that helps
okay next max seaman
i've seen a rundown commercial property
near my area something ideally to be
turned into flats the property isn't on
the market just wondering how you'd go
about approaching the vendor so what i
would do is if there's a rundown
commercial property you think it could
be flats is i would send a letter to the
owner you can find their details on
landregistry.com ask them if they're
open to selling if they are i would see
if i could take that property on on a
12-month option agreement and then i'd
say look what do you want for the
property let's say they say i want 500
grand but you know that if it had
planning permission
it would be worth
700 grand and if you turned it into
flats it'll be worth 1.2 million so
you're going to get an option agreement
for
say 600 grand of course i don't know the
property so i'm just giving uh
hypothetical figures but you ask them
what they want and you say look i'll
give you that figure
in 12 months
you then
secure it on an option agreement so you
have the option to buy in 12 months and
between now and the 12 months what are
you going to do you're going to get
planning permission you're going to push
the value up meaning that in 12 months
you've got yourself an absolutely
fantastic property that's my best advice
hope that helps
rose jackson
if i become a landlady and i move my mom
in there for example can i charge her
the same rate as everyone else or could
i have her a lower rate since she's
family and why do private landlords and
ladies are not so keen on people getting
rent paid through benefits
rose jackson of course you can charge a
less you can charge a tenant whatever
you want in property you can
as long as you've got a willing buyer
and a willing seller you can buy and
sell the price you want you can unless
you're trying to avoid stamps you buy
really really really cheap and then do a
backhander but generally speaking you
can buy and sell for the price you want
you can rent and let at the price you
want so if your mom wants to move in you
want to give a reduced rate you can
absolutely do that why don't people like
renting to people on benefits um because
it's not their demographic it's not
their market your house is your product
and your tenant is your customer and
your in your business you have your own
market some people love renting to
people on benefits other people don't it
just depends on what their business
model is
okay joe brink
with a lease option agreement would it
be wise to get the agent to ask the
seller if he would consider or would
that be trying to cut the middle man out
and would the agent try to talk me down
from that idea as it would prolong the
sale of the property would it be best to
try and contact the seller directly to
ask this question when i see potential
lease option agreements i always write
to the seller direct i cut the agent out
now you might think well that's bad but
the reason is is because these houses
that i've got negative equity they've
often been sitting on rightmove for 10
years they can't sell them because they
are the houses are under water they're
upside down mortgages they're in
negative equity so i'll cut the agent
out
because if i try and explain it to the
agent i'll confuse them and if you
confuse them you lose them and then once
i've got the lease option agreement
secured i'll go back to the agent and i
say hey this property 32 church road it
was actually on with you it's been on
for seven years you couldn't sell it
because of this that and the other
reason however i've just secured on a
lease option agreement deal this is what
happened can i pay your commission and
then what will often happen is then the
agent will say you know what i've got a
whole bunch more of those and then you
can get a whole bunch more they'll
become your free no money down lease
option deal sources hope that helps
okay um
abdullah
do you need an nda while deal sourcing
yes you need a non-disclosure agreement
when deal sourcing always if you're
giving the details up front whether it
be codial sourcing bespoke sourcing or
deal sourcing
i have 30 000 pounds in savings is this
enough to be financially free um well no
not unless you know what you're doing 30
000 pounds
is it enough to be financially free well
that's going to be gone in a year
because it's going to cost about 30
grand just to live roof over your head
and eat so
unless you learn
the skills of securing properties
controlling properties maximizing rents
um
it doesn't matter if you've got zero
thirty or three hundred grand it's all
about who has the skills not who has the
money
what's the best way to remortgage with a
broker all right last question nicole
ripple i'm just turning 16.
congratulations for being on the channel
and i really really really want to get
into property obviously i can't own
property as a child but i will gather
capital for the next two years what's
the best strategy to invest in property
once i turn 18.
um okay so i had the same problem i
started out when i was 17. i was
thinking i can't wait to turn 18 i can
buy houses and then someone told me you
need to be 21 to get a buy to let
mortgage i thought i'm not waiting four
years so then i got super creative and
as a teenager if you're 16 17 18 19 you
don't necessarily have to buy houses to
make money from them you can package and
sell deals
you can control properties there's a lot
of things you can do as an entrepreneur
without having to actually own a
property so i would start doing that and
then when you're old enough or if you
can pull a joint venture partner start
building your own portfolio hope you
found this video helpful ask your
comments some questions below i'll do my
best to answer thanks for watching peace
out god bless